Beamen kennen wir alle von Star Trek und Co.
Und tatsächlich ist Beamen möglich, nämlich
mit Quantenzuständen.
Und das gilt auch als die Schlüsseltechnologie
für Quantenkommunikations-Netzwerke.
Doch das große Problem: Bislang ist man hierbei
immer noch weitestgehend auf den Zufall angewiesen.
Doch damit ist jetzt Schluss: Einem österreichischen
Forschungsteam gelang nämlich ein spektakulärer
Erfolg!
Und ob und wann das Beamen von menschen möglich
ist, das erfahrt ihr in Clixoom Science & Fiction,
hier gibt es jeden Tag spannende Wissenschaftsvideos
- Abonniert den Kanal, nur dann verpasst ihr
nichts Los geht’s!
Herzlich willkommen!
Beamen oder auch Teleportation, wie es auch
genannt wird, ist ja wohl bei weitem das beste
Transportmittel, was man sich überhaupt vorstellen
kann!
In der Theorie gibt es gleich zwei Möglichkeiten,
die die Teleportation möglich machen könnten.
Dazu müsste eine Person entweder in Daten
übertragen werden, um dann am gewünschten
Zielort wieder zu einer physischen Masse verwandelt
werden.
Oder aber die Masse müsste am Ausgangsort
komplett abgebaut werden und dann am gewünschten
Ort wieder rekonstruiert zu werden.
Auch wenn das erst einmal total unrealistisch
klingt, ist das in den Theorie sogar mit den
Gesetzen der Physik vereinbar.
Konkret geht es dabei um das Phänomen der
sogenannten Quantenverschränkung.
Vereinfacht gesagt teilen sich hierbei zwei
Teilchen denselben Zustand - und das, obwohl
eine große Distanz zwischen ihnen liegt.
Forschungsteams weltweit setzen große Hoffnung
in diese Technik, denn darauf basierende Quantenkommunikationsnetzwerke
könnten es in Zukunft möglich machen, auch
über große Distanzen hundertprozentig sicher
verschlüsselte Nachrichten zu übertragen.
In dem Prozess werden verschränkte Paare
von Photonen benötigt.
Diese stammen aus nichtlinearen Kristallen,
in denen ein einzelnes hochenergetisches Photon
in zwei verschränkte Photonen niedrigerer
Energie aufgespalten wird.
Doch der Zufall stellte diesen Forschungsbereich
noch vor eine riesige Herausforderung.
Denn er alleine entschied bislang darüber,
wann ein geeignetes Photonenpaar entsteht.
Technologische Umsetzungen waren somit bislang
- wenn überhaupt - nur eingeschränkt möglich.
Einem Forschungsteam aus Linz ist es jetzt
aber gelungen, den Zufall bei diesem Prozess
zu umgehen.
In ihrem Experiment schafften es die Wissenschaftlerinnen
und Wissenschaftler, verschränkte Photonen
quasi “auf Knopfdruck” zu erzeugen.
Konkret nutzten sie winzige Quantenpunkte;
eingebettet in Halbleiterkristallen.
Dazu wurde ein Aluminium-Gallium-Arsenid-Kristall
verwendet, in dessen Oberfläche ein symmetrisches
Loch geätzt wurde.
Aufgefüllt wurde es mit reinem Gallium-Arsenid.
Somit schaffte das Forschungsteam eine hohe
Symmetrie und Reinheit der Quantenpunkte,
was ihnen letztendlich wohl auch zu ihrem
Erfolg verhalf.
In ihrem Experiment regten sie die Quantenpunkte
durch Laserpulse an und brachten sie somit
dazu, zwei verschränkte Photonen abzugeben.
Dazu einer der beteiligten Forscher, Marcus
Reindl: “Das funktioniert im Grunde auf
Knopfdruck.
Jeder Laserpuls erzeugt mit 90-prozentiger
Wahrscheinlichkeit ein Photonenpaar, das wir
dann für die Teleportation nutzen können”.
Somit wurden tatsächlich Quantenobjekte “on
demand” erzeugt - laut den Angaben des Forschungsteams
weltweit eine Premiere!
Auch, wenn es noch einige Schwachpunkte zu
beheben gibt: Einige Photonen werden kurz
nach ihrer Erzeugung von dem System “verschluckt”,
was natürlich einen Nachteil darstellt.
Das Ergebnis jedenfalls macht große Hoffnung
auf einen technologischen Einsatz von Quantenpunkten
in naher Zukunft.
Dies würde die Quantenkommunikation wiederum
einen riesigen Schritt nach vorne bringen.
Für die Teleportation, wie wir sie auf Filmen
wie Star Trek kennen, bedeutet dies allerdings
keinen wirklichen Fortschritt.
Um diese umzusetzen, und wenn es nur um ein
winziges Staubkorn geht, sind unsere technischen
Möglichkeiten bisher einfach noch längst
nicht ausgereift.
Ein britisches Forschungsteam hatte vor einigen
Jahren (2013) einmal grob überschlagen, dass
das Beamen eines Menschen nicht nur Millionen
Jahre dauern würde.
Sondern es auch der Stand der Technik heutzutage
nicht wirklich zulässt, diese Person sinnvoll
von Standort A zu Standort B zu übertragen.
Denn die Teleportation bräuchte einfach eine
viel zu enorme Datenmenge.
Die nächste große Frage wäre außerdem,
ob man diesen Prozess überhaupt überleben
könnte?
Und wäre die Person nach der Teleportation
überhaupt noch dieselbe?
Trotz dieser viele unzähligen ungelösten
Aspekte zu diesem Thema, gibt es einige Fachleute,
die dennoch optimistisch sind.
Dazu gehört beispielsweise der US-Physiker
Michio Kaku, der davon ausgeht, dass es uns
Menschen spätestens im nächsten Jahrhundert
gelingt, uns zu teleportieren.
What!
Wenn ihr die ersten sein wollt, die davon
erfahren, dann folgt mir auf WhatsApp, denn
da bekommt ihr alle Infos vor allen anderen
exklusiv von mir persönlich!
Einfach hier drauf klicken.
Und ganz wichtig: Meine Nummer unbedingt in
euren Kontakten speichern!
Wir hören und sehen und schreiben uns dort!
Bis dann, bleibt dran!